الى ايران مشاهدينا حيث لا تزال السلطات
تواصل عمليات الاعتقال التي توصف بالتعسفي
بحق ناشطين في حقوق الانسان حيث اعتقلت
الناشطه الاجتماعيه في مجال حقوق المراه
والطفل محييه واحد وذلك وفقا لتقارير
اعلاميه وحقوقيه هذا واكد شقيقه محيا مثيم
وحيدي اعتقال شقيقته حيث نشر عبر حسابه في
تويتر تغريده قال فيها ان شقيقته اعتقلت
في مكان عملها ظهر امس الاحد دون اي تفسير
كما تمت اجهزتها الالكترونيه
المفرج عنها ليلى حسين زاد عن الحاله
الماساويه للنساء في سجن شيراز بعد ما
اخرج عنها مؤقتا بكفاله وقالت ذهب في
تغريدات على تويتر
يستخدم حبوب اعصاب مجهوله الاسم لسجينات
موضحا ان هذه الادويه ادت الى تشنجات
عصبيه بين النساء السجينات وتعرضت زاد
للسجن اثناء الاحتجاجات المتواصله في
البلاد منذ اربعه اشهر بسبب مقتل الفتاه
الايراني
فيها من قبل من قبل ما يعرف بشرطه الاخلاق
انا ذاكر